he's the idea in the real world right in
the real world when quantities change
there are many many different kinds of
good many many different kinds of
quantities that chain in proportion to
this they change your proportion to this
size so if I just keep a quantity that's
changing and then write the fancy way we
would say this is how that right thing
is changing with respect to time that's
just a spur growth rate orange betrayed
right and we actually have a symbol
which looks suspiciously like the
character alpha but it's not meant to be
which means is proportional to the size
of the thing itself okay this is the
proper proportionality symbol okay we'll
come back to this relationship in a
minute this idea of the rate at which
something changes being proportional to
its size it should make sense right
because for example you got more rabbit
mummies you can make more rabbit things
right because every rabbit maybe not
every that baby but maybe half of them
or I don't know what the proportion is
it's going to become you know of
something they can't pudding add to the
population yeah
and this is not the only case in which
this sum in which this occurs will go
the wrong way
sorry in fact pretty much anything where
you've got some kind of population where
the more of them that there are the more
scrab there is to create more like the
more viruses there are the more self
factories they didn't take over and what
do you think about a baker killer a
banking out works exactly the same way
because as a bank account earns
interests the interest itself becomes
something they can also an interest so
that's why it does this presuming you
don't take any money okay so this idea
of the great mentor changing you know as
this gets bigger this also against
people right so in other words as it
gets bigger it grows faster this should
be not surprising to us okay but in
addition to that this also can happen
here
yes it also happens in Reverse so when
you have something which is not getting
bigger every time but getting smaller
radioactive decays the perfect example
right because the more stuff there is
right the more radioactive material that
you have and you know you guys know me
and my happens background not gonna
pretend everything that I understand
everything but I understand enough to
know what's an energy loss of bats which
is equivalent to awesome energy the more
stuff there is to radiate out of energy
than therefore mass well the more
educated therefore mass you will lose
over time okay so as that thing gets
smaller and smaller though you've got
less material to radiate so it's that
growth rate again as this gets smaller
this is gonna get smaller to its lows
down right
this happens in lots of situations heat
transfer heat transfer well you have a
hot object in a cold environment right
that temperature is getting lower lower
lower and as that temperature approaches
we havea temper job it sort of smooth
down so in that first like be the octave
boiling water or after you've poured it
into the cup of coffee the cup itself is
called
the environment is called it rapidly
loses typical did I get another one yeah
the same kind of thing happens whenever
you're you've got gas to your food the
lower the concentration is right the
more it slows down okay
this is you can see when it's all
concentrated LBT you've got a high cliff
situation it's gonna be really quickly
over as soon as you open the mouth but
as it sort of spreads out and as the
concentration concentration you get
slower but the rate of change of that
concentration will eventually it just
kind of hits or the quality Calibri of
you know it's like yeah okay everything
is diffuse okay
oh not only that but you rember I said
let's let's think back here right here
we go
if you've got a bank account is getting
bigger and bigger over time right and
it's gaining interest then in storage
you calculate it's going to accrue more
interest over time but if it's that you
start with a pile of money
and instead of putting figs in you stop
taking these out right so like a
superannuation fund after someone has
retired so they're gonna start to
withdraw money out of that right now if
that was just literally a pile of cash
then as you draw money out at a constant
rate it's just going to go down like
this in a straight line right but
because it's still there in a bank
you're actually burning interest right
it tries to pull up it tries to slow
down so you're getting this kind of
relationship again it gets smaller the
rate of change also slows down okay so
what we do is in order to work with this
a little more sound regretfully we say
instead of saying this is proportional
to that let's take this as an equation
so to say that something is proportional
or something else is to say that one is
a product pleasure of the other okay and
for the sake of convenience we don't
just say that K is a is it closer but
that it's a positive constant because
then that gets us to two different kinds
of statements right
good morning if you've got something
that's growing like this right and K is
going to be well it's gonna be a
positive number but if you have
something like say this then this
indicates you okay excited this whole
thing is negative so it's getting
smaller right so we call this a great
situation this is growing over here and
we call this a decay situation right so
this idea of growth and decay because it
happens in the natural well this is
often called natural growth and decay
but what we think about this there is
one kind of equation that we know that
fits this kind of um just kind of pad
that way you differentiate it right what
you get back is a version of itself only
off by a cluster don't remember right we
know in lots of different kinds of
just for example we don't polynomial
functions well you differentiate these
though let's call this 7x you don't just
get back another version of x squared
okay we know what happens to this power
the same kind of thing happens there's
like a fundamental change if you look at
say a trig function when you
differentiate it you get a whole
different functions back its space
shifted but we know there's one other
kind of watches a few other points but
there's one other kind of a function
that's gonna be fitting this which is
namely the exponential right so this is
the classic example but even all the
other ones right if you choose a base
other than e to the X you'll get like
some multiple of that so for example two
to the X or a more generally and e to
the X is just that particular example
where log E is just one right so
therefore we often call this not just
natural growth decay but exponential
growth as you can it seems a bit funny
to say something is exponentially
decaying that seems to suggest it's
getting faster faster faster but in fact
it's not it's getting slower and slower
slower so you're getting a different
kind of graph right if you want to drop
draw a really small we're familiar with
an exponential growth situation just out
of small and it just sort of skyrockets
but the decay situation it takes it in
reverse like so so this is why some
people prefer the nomenclature of
natural growth indicators rather than
exponential okay but I like the word
exponential I like using it as a
because it gets us in the right category
of people these are the functions that
are near the top us here okay so our one
last vote before we actually start to
look at the mechanics of this are these
two teens that have written to you these
two are what we call differential
equations differential equations for the
very many of you who are going to study
at least some form of maths
definitely firstly because if you go
into anything science or engineering
plated you're gonna do an undergraduate
maths at least for one year you're gonna
be differential equations a lot rather
than a derivative being a function of
whatever variable you're interested in
you've got the derivative as a function
of the original or the primitive that's
where you came from right so you'll
often see I mean I could just as easily
everything this as let's say okay P -
zero okay so this is you know family of
these called differential equations
again sort of leading forward to those
of you who are going to discover it the
particular kind of differential
equations I've written here are two
things firstly they're called a
first-order because all I've got is the
first derivative here you can see I've
got P - if I had a P double dash it
there it had been a first-order but
second order I'm sure the first order
the other thing that's important of
these is they're called ordinary classic
mathematician understatement which is to
set which is a mathematicians way of
saying there's only a single variable
independent variable involved this
population only depends on a single
thing namely time which we'll look at in
a second as you can imagine this is not
always the case right you remember I
said a rabbit population that's going to
change but doesn't just change with
respect to time it also might change
with respect to climate change with
respect to creditors change with all
these kinds of things right so if you've
got more different like independent
variables going into here we don't call
them ordinary additional equations we
call them partial differential equations
all of your derivatives are with respect
to one group one variable or another so
you can
first order second order third order you
can get ordinary we will get partial
what's really nice is this this we're
looking at first-order ordinary
differential equations we call them
foods anyhow that's that's not that's
not oh well no no there's not a
well-established acronym but that's
exactly what it is
yes release anyway you will hear the
language of differential equations and
des a lot in the future the vast
majority of you anyhow so I'm just
teasing that for you you'll encounter
them